that's the [ __ ] three I was waiting
for he's got pair of fours wait you know
what I have no II did he said he's got a
pair you didn't know what I had you
cheatin son of the old watching g-men
you guys doing [ __ ] [ __ ] about extra
extra in the newsboy he's playing his
[ __ ] cars raw as well they hit a 4x
all right if that's how you saw it
why did you lie at first and try to say
it was him you sneaky bastard
Bobby Lee Bobby Lee what all these years
of knowing you my uh-oh could you see
this don't put it on your [ __ ] little
line that's what it is I have these
little Asian eyes I don't have
peripheral so every time I look I have
been how did you know my head why did
you put it on him first you lie if you
were telling the truth you would have
just told on a second - if you go if you
want to say it's just a gut feeling from
you improv you felt that baby throw you
under the bus
yeah okay okay just say something yeah I
got cheated all right then you're right
Wow no of the no no good night I'm with
a late kick out get out of this and when
I eat because I look those cards win if
I was doing that and that's how we saw
him that's what he would have said that
was someone order [ __ ] [ __ ] the reason
why I did that was because I got caught
in a lie right and I'm a survivor you
hadn't lied yet I know
[Music]
you